nous sommes en 2013
marc andré fortier ex pdg de la société
immobilière du québec se dirige vers une
salle d'audience du palais de justice de
québec
il est dans le pétrin son ancien
employeur lui réclame 80 mille dollars
en dépenses injustifiées
on a trouvé des irrégularités dans les
comptes de monsieur fortier notamment
des invitations golfe notamment des
comptes de dépenses absolument
incroyable la ministre responsable ne
fait ni une ni deux climats la porte
pour se défendre au procès marc andré
fortier est prêt à embarrasser le
gouvernement à qui il doit sa nomination
en 2003 j'ai parlé d un peu jaser
d'éviction de charme des jeux
j'étais le premier gouvernement charest
prend le pouvoir en avril 2003
les relations de marc andré fortier ont
bien travaillé les relations qui vous a
dit delneri
ça fait toujours du bureau des emplois
supérieurs
le secrétariat aux emplois supérieurs
c'est là qu'on décide qui occupera les
plus hauts postes de la fonction
publique
on m'a demandé de le rencontrer gpo et
éblouis par monsieur fortier je dois
vous avouer qu'à 10 mans mais la
ministre confirme tout de même sa
nomination marc andré fortier gère
désormais la société immobilière dont la
mission est de loger au meilleur rapport
qualité-prix tous les fonctionnaires
sauf le réseau de la santé d'éducation
lorsque vous
une petite pancarte bleus c'est un
immeuble que possèdent ou que loue la
société dès qu'il en devient le pdg marc
andré fortier aurait participé un plan
pour s'enrichir en s'alliant avec une
collecteurs de fonds du parti libéral
dès son arrivée en poste à la société
immobilière la sic
marc andré fortier demande et obtient du
gouvernement
le changement complet du conseil
d'administration lorsque je suis arrivé
nous étions un nouveau conseil
d'administration
tous les administrateurs était nouveau
il est à la fois pdg et président du
conseil d'administration et personne ne
doute que c'est lui le patron
c'était quelqu'un qui était agressé paul
bons mots c'est quelqu'un qui était très
sûr de lui il ya mason gagner marc andré
fortier embauche un bras droit pierre
fournier qui devient vice-président pour
l'est du québec
ensemble ils font rapidement des choses
qui paraissent bien étrange aux yeux de
certains employés
en 2004 fortier fournissaient l'eau
demande de bruno arnold le pdg de
roumare tu gères cet immeuble où le
gouvernement lui presque tous les étages
il obtient un bail de dix sept ans bien
plus long que la grande majorité des
baux de la sic
normalement le gouvernement d'après ce
que je vois dans les tendances du marché
recours plutôt à des échéances vos taux
de 10,1 pour est en mesure de contrôler
l'évolution des coûts les loyers de
bureaux
un autre gestionnaire d'immeubles
christian guy d'edf corp veut aussi des
baux de longue durée pour les immeubles
qu'ils gèrent aux 200 chemin sainte foy
et où neuf sandouville
évidemment vous comprenez que lorsqu'on
a le locataire qui s'appelle le
gouvernement du québec
celui d'un président russe est à peu
près nulles
ce point là qatar qui va faire faillite
christian guay est exaucé en juillet
2006 pierre fourny signent un bail de 20
ans pour le neuf sandouville et une
entente de 25 ans pour le 205 x
même si ce bail venait tout juste d'être
renouvelé je pense que ce propriétaire
leur fait une bonne affaire cette
journée là ainsi cette prolongation bol
alors pourquoi forty fournis ont
approuvé ces ententes
c'est ici à berne en suisse au quartier
général de la police fédérale que
s'amorce en 2007 une enquête qui se
retrouvera quatre ans plus tard sur le
bureau de christian plourde à québec et
ont découvert des mouvements d'argent
partant de suez ce belgique d'un vélo
québec jusqu'à son départ en 2015
christian plourde a dirigé l'équipe
d'enquêteurs de l'upac qui a poursuivi
le travail de la police suisse l'enquète
provient d'une demande d'entraidé de la
suisse nous ont demandé de faire un bout
de chemin dans le dossier pour de suivi
de l'argent les gens qui étaient visés
concernés par l'enquêté ces choses
cette enquête est baptisée projet
justesse le projet justice nous a été
présenté comme un petit dossier facile
clé en main la terminologie clé en main
qui devait se régler entre être et
[ __ ] ce sera l'anc est la plus longue
et compliquée de sa carrière des
documents de la police suisse nous
apprennent qu'une semaine après le
renouvellement des bons dans ces
immeubles
christian guy de dave cole fait un
paiement de plus de deux millions de
dollars
un consultant en immobilier de montréal
est-ce que c'était la première fois que
vous donniez une commission 2 millions
un consultant
probablement il a fait un travail lomé à
froid la carte est énorme pour un homme
c'est discutable
le consultant transfèrent l'argent qui
passerait de compte en banque un compte
en banque par la belgique jusqu'à la
suisse pour aboutir aux bahamas le
titulaire de ce conte est un notable du
québec
sinon qu'on a vu sortir l'été monsieur
ben athlète qui est un organisateur
libéral william butler aurait reçu près
d'un million mais ils auraient partagé
une partie de cette somme au moyen de
trois traite bancaire
la première pour marc andré fortier qui
aurait reçu 170 mille dollars soit
l'équivalent de son salaire annuel de p
dg de la sic
les deux autres traites bancaires sont
pour les collecteurs de fonds du parti
libéral charles rondeau et franco fava
qui aurait reçu chacun cent mille
dollars
certaines personnes qui sont impliquées
au niveau des transactions immobilières
sont des gens qu'on connaît des jours
qu'on a déjà entendu parler qui ont été
dans l'actualité récente
à ce moment là on voit ces acteurs l'eau
qui sortent de l'ong sort de nos boîtes
et puis évidemment on fait le lien avec
leur affiliation politique
christian guy de dave cobb dit qu'il
ignore tout de ce qui est arrivé des 2
millions qu'il a donné à son consultant
qui a fêté ses 100 ans après avec qui a
partagé
il m'a donné ces renseignements l'aurait
jamais demandé qu'ils fuyaient proclamé
par la police suisse a découvert une
autre transaction qui serait en lien
avec la sic et qui remonte à 2004
quatre dépôts dans des comptes aux
bahamas
selon les documents les titulaires de
ces camps sont marc andré fortier franco
fava charles rondeau et william bartlett
qui se seraient partagés plus d'un
million de dollars j'ai perçu 1 date du
24 décembre 2004 transfert de 200 mille
dollars dans votre compte
anna se millions $ proviendrait d'une
part au liechtenstein et le virement
effet à la demande de bruno arnold pdg
d'euro mart quelques semaines seulement
après l'obtention d'un bail de dix sept
ans avec la société immobilière
marc andré fortier nie avoir touché de
l'argent
moi je lui remets dans votre compte dans
ce conte le nom de marc andré fortier
200 mille dollars
vous avez jamais
de compte aux bahamas nous voulions
connaître ses liens avec williams bat
l'aide franco fava et charles rondeau
mais il n'a pas voulu poursuivre la
discussion
de l'argent en suisse aux bahamas
nous allons revisiter la commission
bastarache qui a fait connaître charles
rondeau et franco fava au grand public
en 2010 mais d'abord on veut le savoir
kiwi mba tlet on apprend que c'est un
ami de franco fava et qu'il est lui
aussi collecteurs de fonds du parti
libéral
ah oui lit très actif dans le comté de
jean talon à québec à l'élection de 2007
philippe couillard était l'hymne avec
les et que je prends la parole
aujourd'hui pour parler surtout de ma
circonscription
oui on bâcle être fait partie de son
équipe de campagne de remercier
particulièrement moubarak le premier
d'un chamois le mieux puis on découvre
qu'il était vice-président à la société
immobilière dans les années 90 nous
allons rencontrer son ancien patron jean
vézina nommé pdg en 1995 avec le mandat
de faire un grand ménage à lacets qui ça
coûte trop cher et respecte à polisy
léger créanciers ni du budget et ça
marche à peaugres jean visinand à mener
une grande réforme qui a été unanimement
saluée les journaux de l'époque ont fait
l'éloge de sa gestion
il se souvient très bien de l'état de la
sic
à son arrivée en 95
on avait pour 250 et table comme le but
lui fouet et quelques la grandeur du
juge yves hocher sorte qu'elle devait
les québécois paient pour les espaces
fils ils découvrent des transactions
suspectes dans ces immeubles et demande
au vérificateur général d'enquêter
verdict les québécois se sont fait avoir
d'environ 70 millions de dollars dans
une dizaine de location des espaces
inutiles ou trop cher on se fait voler
cette loi
moi je te le disais patronat à vos du
patronat n'ont plus le patronat
qu'est ce que ces transactions la à 20
ans comme un an comme un seul et même
temps au dossier william bartlett est
entré à la sic
en 1988 il a été directeur des
transactions immobilières et vice
président un poste stratégique
il serait selon nos sources impliquées
dans plusieurs de ses transactions en
pas du tout confiance en eux ils le
congédie en 1995
je ne voulais pas qu'on fasse de la
politique d'aucune façon et lui
manifestement les premières
conversations que j'ai eues avec lui il
faisait de la politique
après avoir congédié williams bartlett
jean vézina mais son subalterne à la
porte un certain pierre fournier quand
il apprend
quatre ans plus tard que son successeur
marc andré fortier l'a nommé vice
président il n'en revient pas vicoise
offert l'or pour se trouver ce train de
le gault kamba d'or puis engagé mais il
ya une décision que j'envie zina
comprend encore moins le sud président
dans son message inaugural le premier
ministre a invoqué ce budget comme étant
celui de la transparence et de la
rigueur
le 24 mai 2007 monique jérôme forget
fait une annonce importante dans le
budget du québec
nous allons également mettre en vente
trois immeubles qui sont la propriété de
la société immobilière du québec
les gains de la vente de ces immeubles
seront versés au fonds des générations
de surface en plastique banderas sic
trois immeubles mais deviendra locataire
de la majorité des espaces encore
aujourd'hui je ne crois pas clé dans la
mission du gouvernement d'être
propriétaires d'édifices encore
aujourd'hui je maintiens la ligne et je
vous dirais que ce que j'ai fait je ne
suis pas allé assez loin
certains administrateurs ne comprennent
pas les avantages de cette transaction
il avait des gens qui croyaient qu'on ne
devrait pas vendre
ces immeubles la maison convaincra pas
l'ancien ministre de cela ce qui s'est
passé dans les faits c'est que en avant
du troisième pour les relouer de toute
façon et faire quelque chose qui était à
l'avantagé des gens qui envoient tout
c'est votre opinion
je ne suis pas certaine que vous sachiez
content et très bien
des transactions de plus de 250 millions
de dollars sont sur le point de se faire
les policiers ont enquêté cinq ans pour
échafauder une théorie sur ce qui s'est
tramé dans les bureaux de la société
immobilière du québec à cette époque
c'est la plus grande fraude immobilière
qui aurait eu lieu
je pense au québec et au canada quand on
parle de fraude immobilière explique un
des organismes gouvernementaux
las québec à côté du parlement et mise
en vente les acheteurs retenu
deviendront des vedettes de la
commission charbonneau de dollars et son
élément de vérité toute la vérité sur ma
liberté visionner alors pdg de solim le
bras immobilier du fonds de solidarité
ftq fait alliance avec tougne incursion
qui se passe de présentation aux
professions entre pas visionné a
expliqué aux enquêteurs pourquoi sollima
cure so ont embauché williams barclays
pour les aider à négocier
il disait qu'il avait un accès
privilégié auprès de gens à la sic qui
lui permettait de l'aider dans la
négociation et de favoriser à son
avantage la négociation avec quels gens
là sic par une lette avait-il des accès
privilégiés
le président est celui qui négociait le
vice président pierre fournier brigitte
m'a dit qu'il contrôlait le conseil de
la sic
au terme des négociations les acheteurs
estime avoir fait une bonne affaire
un prix réduit un bail de 20 ans avec la
sic il dit loyer majoré de 30 6%
avez vous été témoin de cadeaux et où
montant d'argent que bilbao lequel est
aurait remis à un ou des dirigeants de
la cik témoin non mais bill parlait
qu'il était très près des dirigeants et
qu'il s'en servait pour faciliter la
négociation
moi j'en ai conclu que s'il avait ces
résultats-là s'entraîne et possiblement
des contreparties
mais nous n'avons encore rien vu il
reste encore deux immeubles à vendre
filles
vienne capitale de l'autriche
une ville magnifique où l'histoire et
l'architecturé font la joie des
touristes
bien discrète sur la valeur strass au
centre ville se trouve leur âme bank une
banque privée
par un beau matin de l'été 2008 l'un de
ces bancs qui reçoit un courriel un peu
sec courriel que nous avons obtenus
d'une source anonyme l'auteur est un
client du québec
il s'appelle william bartlett j'aimerais
beaucoup que vous êtes abonné pour
régler cette situation ridicule s'il
vous plaît rappelez moi avec des
résultats ou des nouvelles au plus vite
william porte l'aide at amp une grosse
somme d'argent en lien avec une autre
transaction immobilière après avoir été
fort utile pour les acheteurs de place
québec
il travaille aussi pour celui qui
achètera les deux autres immeubles
georges d'un chef la campagne chut on
peut le garder pour moi management
georges guen chef un très gros joueur de
l'immobilier au québec fait la meilleure
offre pour les deux immeubles
le 500 rené-lévesque ouest qui situé
dans l'un des secteurs les plus
convoités du centre ville de montréal et
le complexe jia tardif qui fait tout un
quadrille à terre près du complexe g à
québec
mais le processus d'approbation des
offres d'achat donnent lieu à une
étrange réunion du conseil
d'administration
il y avait eu une rencontre à montréal
dans un restaurant sur la rue notre dame
un endroit peu approprié je voudrais
aujourd'hui et on pourra voir ces deux
rencontres des membres du ca ce sans
bousculer par marc andré fortier le p dg
de la sic et son vice président pierre
fournier qu'on n'était vraiment pas la s
avec avec la façon que ça se déroulait
non on va en voir reprendre ça dans un
formant un petit peu plus approprié avec
la meilleure documentation possible
d'une chaise avec une assiette de
spaghetti en avant nous finalement les
membres du conseil vont quand même
approuvé l'avant des deux derniers
immeubles la ministre au fel annonce
avec plaisir pour le total monsieur le
président c'est 265 millions le prix de
vente
il y avait en termes de gains si on peut
parler de profit ces 133 millions de
dollars qui seront déposés au fonds des
générations
on a fait 40 millions de plus que ce
qu'on avait prévu
donc la vente ont rapporté quelque chose
retour à vienne en autriche dans les
bureaux de leurs banques
le banquier de william mbaye toilettes
en régler les problèmes qui l'empêchait
de recevoir son argent cher bill
de notre côté on est prêt nous attendons
votre transfert william berkley tu écris
à son banquier qui l'attend une très
grosse somme de la part de gan chef et
d'un autre de ses associés le payeur a
décidé d'envoyer les paiements de
plusieurs sources de divers montants qu
un total d'environ 7 millions $
cet argent est selon toutes les
apparences en lien avec les deux
immeubles que gagnent je viens d'acheter
veuillez spécifié dans les instructions
de transfert de fonds pour grande-allée
425 475 saint-amable rené lévesque ouest
montréal québec
cela garantira un transfert sans
problème nous avons tenté de parler à
monsieur gagnent chef mais il n'a pas
donné suite à notre demande qu'a bien pu
faire williams bartlett pour s'attendre
à 7 millions de dollars
nous recevons une enveloppe brune qui
contient un rapport juricomptable
commandé par la sic en 2012 quatre ans
après les ventes
les conclusions sont explosives on
découvre ligue dessous de la transaction
il y avait des modifications par rapport
à des cloches de frais d'exploitation et
cetera qui n'était pas du tout conforme
et puis ce seront le nous l'avons su par
la suite selon le rapport fortier
fournier ont fait de très grosses
concessions acheteurs
les boues sont passés de 10 à 20 ans les
loyers sont augmenté partout mais cela
n'a jamais été dit au moment de mettre
les immeubles en vente aux entreprises
qui ont participé à l'appel d'offres
alors tous les acheteurs potentiels ont
pas eu la même information
un acheteur potentiel qui dit un
bâtiment xv aux 50 millions mais avoir
su qui était louée de 25 prochaines
années et il valait pas cinquante mille
valence ce week end pour moi mais comme
je lé pot sujet pas aux beats des
anguilles mais jupo fait l'offre
correspondante à la valeur réelle de
l'immeuble
tout cela et d'autres clauses procure
des avantages financiers très importants
acheteurs selon deux rapports 13
millions de dollars pour place québec et
34 millions de dollars pour lui 9j à
tardif et le 500 rené lévesque total des
avantages financiers aux acheteurs 47
millions de dollars
nous retournons à québec montrer ce
rapport à janvier ina il prouve que
manigance good à l'eau il s'agissait de
vendre nos plus haut prix porté à s'y
faire des concessions sur tout les plans
pour que le pays soit encore plus élevée
mais les concessions c'est assez qui
paient le gouvernement une fois ou
d'organiser sa parole
nous avons parlé du rapport
juricomptable la pierre fournier et ce
n'est pas tout en plus des avantages
financiers
la siq a accepté l'ajout de cette clause
que les travaux majeurs pour 20 ans soit
à la charge du locataire du gouvernement
le gouvernement va payer pour les
dépenses de nature structural le
propriétaire n'assume aucune dépense
sont liés à la détention d'immeubles
même pas changé les flammes pour changer
les freins les murs extérieurs alors
faire la toiture c'est le locataire
le gouvernement est responsable du
paiement de tous et des bouts de toutes
ces dépenses là en cours de bail ce trip
ou vente à désirer ce qui est vraiment
aux crises celui-ci s'est un peu de ses
propriétaires qui décident tout ce
moment là
elie nouveau propriétaire décide de
rénover aux frais des contribuables
parfois un peu comme ici aux 500 rené
lévesque
mais ici rénovation extrême l'immeuble a
été vidé et reconstruit presqu'à 9
le gouvernement a du pays 13 millions de
dollars pour ces travaux vous avez été
le propriétaire à la fin de cette
transaction aulas comment vous seriez
saadi ça a été une bonne journée
un placement un calcul très conservateur
permet de conclure que par toutes les
clauses ajouté ce sont au moins 60
millions de dollars davantage pour les
acheteurs
qui nous a trompés bien je dirais que
c'est ce sont les personnes qui étaient
responsables du dossier
alors marc fortier pendant le temps
qu'il était là et bien fourni on va
rester sur lot
le gouvernement a décidé un devin trop
l'immeuble pour nettoyer chercher la
meilleure transaction possible dans
l'échec rosstat quant à william burns
lettre son avocat nous écrit nous avons
soigneusement analysé les informations
contenues
en vérité ces faits sont en partie
inexacte efforts tendancieusement
présenté par temps nous ne commenterons
pas davantage la situation
nous avions exposé à william bartlett
les frais de ce reportage le concernant
avec lui vend cette dernière transaction
qu'il implique
janvier 2008
william berkley tu donnes d'autres
instructions à son banquier en autriche
à propos de mon récent dépôt d'un
million de dollars pourriez vous
transférez de mai quant au nouveau camp
de monsieur franco fava monsieur charles
rondeau respectivement la somme de 422
1572 dollars mais il ne s'agit plus
d'une transaction avec la société
immobilière
cette lettre de franco fava destinés à
la banque nous fait découvrir qu'un
autre organisme du gouvernement du
québec serait impliqué ceci est ma part
de revenus et de commissions pour une
transaction concernant le renouvellement
d'un bail au 11 99 bleury à montréal 11
99 bleury c'est l'immeuble qui abrite
les bureaux de la csst ou cnrs est cité
comme on dit maintenant un organisme qui
n'a rien à voir avec la sic des
documents démontrent que pendant les
mois précédents le pm en autriche
william butler hill franco fava ont
travaillé ensemble pour un prolongement
du bail de 20 ans qui sera signé en
décembre 2007 mais le problème c'est
qu'à ce moment franco fava siège au
conseil d'administration de la csst et
ce depuis 20 ans l'immeuble appartient
une entreprise incorporée au panama avec
une adresse en suisse qui s'appelle
genser impossible de connaître le vrai
propriétaire
nous avons tenté d'obtenir la version
des faits de franco fava
sur l'ensemble des allégations dans
notre reportage
il nie avoir des comptes à l'étranger
faisait pas reçu un dats 24 décembre
2004 le transfert de 200 mille dollars
dans votre compte en national je ne suis
pas au point de renier
j'ai rien à vous dire fabien arakelian
avez vous un compte
nous avons également offert à charron
d'eau l'occasion de s'expliquer je vais
parler de transactions à la société
immobilière puis je veux parler de votre
compte de banques en autriche aussi il
ne nous a jamais rappelés
ce sont des gens qui se sont associés de
façon très ouverte l'époque avec le
premier ministre qui était en poste
on sait que c'est des gens qui se sont
affichés comme des amis du premier
ministre c'est le quotidien des gens les
enquêteurs du pack par définition
lorsqu'on est inquiètant clemente
organisé communauté financière organisée
ou encore options on est toujours
nécessaire gouvernementales mais l'on se
rende compte qu'on était pas mal proche
premier étage nous quittons la sphère
immobilière pour enquêter sur la
dimension politique
charles rondeau et franco fava qui sont
ces deux hommes pourquoi se serait-il
mérité sept cent mille dollars dans le
cadre de transactions immobilières face
à la fraude j'ai sur sa faim ça
s'appelait la fraude ça la posture d'un
bout à l'autre
chaque soulève des hypothèses tellement
élevé que il faut une enquête en
profondeur
c'est justement au cours d'une enquête
publique que beaucoup de québécois ont
découvert ces deux hommes mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir les allégations sont
graves et elle vise directement le
gouvernement de jean charest
en 2010 le gouvernement déclenche la
commission bastarache
après des déclarations shop de marc
bellemare l'ex ministre de la justice
dit que franco fava a fait pression sur
lui pour qu'il nomme des juges son ami
charles rondeau est aussi mis en cause
ils ont tous nient je regarde tout chaud
sur tomber sa taille c'était ma première
réaction c'est quelqu'un qui a du sine
c'est un débat sur les valeurs
dans son rapport michel bastarache
conclut que marc bellemare n'a pas été
contraint de nommer des juges
mais ce qui frappe en réécoutant leurs
témoignages celle influence de rondeau
et fava au plq
ils sont des champions de la collecte de
fonds les conti qui étaient sous notre
responsabilité en faire pour les trois
comtés de l'est entre 1.5 1.6 1.7 de
panama des années un million et demi et
plus par année et tout ce travail pour
financer le parti
ils l'ont fait bénévolement sous parler
de mon intérêt à mon personnel ouais
pécunier sont absolument briller
un remerciement de jean charest pendant
un discours leur suffit de ce genre n
pour la mersey sanaa très content ce
match était payé est un taux un peu
sommaire ma paye encore non merci
mais il n'était pas vie bénévoles
ordinaire il avait d'autres accès plus
personnel à jean charest le premier
ministre appelé charles rondeau pour son
anniversaire et un soir de novembre 2003
le premier ministre a aussi invité fava
rondeau et d'autres collecteurs de fonds
a eu souper à son appartement de
fonction
à la commission on apprend qu'il
recommande des gens pour des postes a
dit conseil d'administration et dans la
haute fonction publique moi je suis une
courroie de transmission finale mais
j'ai des gens qui montrent un intérêt à
faire quelque chose et je les mets dans
ma chine pour qu'ils vont très bien ce
qu'ils ont à choisir des candidats la
phase avec une banque de données qui se
sont constitués vous êtes intervenu pour
la domination de quelqu'un là c'est ce
projet sont un exemple c'est en effet
vécu c'est exact mais peut-être oui ou
non me faire dos oui bon ok
est ce que marc andré fortier aurait
aussi bénéficié de l'affluence de fava
et rondeau pour être nommé p dg de la
sic
souvenez vous de son témoignage à son
procès et selon lui la ministre n'a pu
qu'approuver le choix de ces relations
parce qu'elle était forcément vers l'ex
p dg de la sic fréquentes franco fava et
charles rondeau depuis longtemps et dans
l'esprit du p dg de la sic
il n'y a pas de frontières entre les
contrats donnés par sa société d'état et
le parti libéral on voit apparaître
comme challenge et la culture monsieur
fabre on voit dernis plq depuis mars et
contre et c'est quoi le lieu où
l'intérêt du parti libéral avec des
contrats de la sic le lien cela même si
le bureau de x men s appelle dès 10h25
en inde elle puis intel région de ce
drame
le pdg d'une société d'état dit que des
collecteurs de fonds ont le même poids
que le bureau du premier ministre pour
que l'enfant leur inconscient j'étais de
savoir si on avait des gros projets
jandin et les autres en tant que soliste
areva dément mais ce cas on peut passer
votre chemin du retour de change avec
l'euro
des retours d'ascenseur est ce possible
que l'argent qu'ils auraient reçu dans
leurs comptes à l'étranger
retournez au parti c'est sûr que
puisqu'on voit des connecteurs la
logique veut qu'on puisse se regarder
cet aspect là haut et film mais on n'a
pas démontré en tout cas au moment où je
suis parti c'était pour démontrer hasard
ou non plusieurs personnes autour des
entreprises qui ont acheté des immeubles
de la sic ont donné généreusement parti
libéral l'année des transactions mais
jamais avant ni après autre fait
troublant 100 % des membres du conseil
d'administration de la cik nommé avec
l'arrivée de marc andré fortier ont un
lien avec le parti libéral
ils sont bénévoles donateurs ou en liait
avec charles rondeau et franco fava ce
pas le rôle de portraits sont un peu
comme boulanger favorise pas peut-être
complaisance
non non il n'y a vraiment personne qui
se connaissaient nos noms ont été
avancés par diverses personnes au bureau
du premier ministre ou aux emplois
supérieurs mais on n'est pas un groupe
d'amis assis autour de la table c'était
pas du tout des roberts a vraiment là
depuis le début
lorsque les gens avaient des questions à
poser les questions étaient posées
est-ce que c'est à votre connaissance
que plusieurs membres du conseil
d'administration
il ya des organisateurs politiques
libéraux qui ont grandement contribué à
leur installation conseil
d'administration
sauf sincèrement je pourrais pas vous
dire je ne sais je ne saurais vous dire
si le conseil d'administration c'est
clair que la cites
peut-être que je devrais pas dire ça
mais d'aller sur le conseil
d'adminstration de la sic
ah c'est pas le plus prestigieux moi
j'irai jamais sur nos conseils
démonstrations placez vous et toute la
difficulté à l'automne dan dah pas bon
là dedans c'est ces pauvres c'est peu
prestigieux
il lit vous sur le conseil
d'administration de la sienne vos j'ai
aucune compétence pour faire ça oui mais
ça vous entraînez ça vous tente pas
m'être déjà compétents l'importance de
compétence du personnel compétent pour
arriver à nice en masse et non non le
conseil d'administration elle ne nous
connaissaient pas alors je sais pas d'où
elles prin ses propos de dire que
c'était une gagne 2 po bon
les enquêtes du vérificateur général
les enquêtes internes et celles de
l'upac indique que depuis très longtemps
le 6 très poreuse haut patronage aux
influences politiques et qu'ils
échappent parfois à la surveillance du
gouvernement
c'est clair que vous semblez indiqué
qu'il était anormal que je ne penche pas
sur ça sincèrement ça ne m'intéressait
pas ça ne m'intéressait pas patel jordi
est intéressé - monique jérôme forget ça
ne m'intéresse pas
la cites ne m'intéressait pas
rien n'est dit que l'ex-ministre quoi
que ce soit à voir avec les fraudes
alléguées à la sic
au contraire elle a collaboré à l'anc
est de l'upac
cette enquête s'est heurté à de
nombreuses difficultés
comme presque toutes les enquêtes en
crimes économiques le meurtre à martic
la voix qualifié saint voy qualifier
c'est clair mais lorsqu'on joue dans
l'argent on s'y baigne opte donc y avait
pas d si mauvaises intentions sur il
pensait peut-être que ça allait être
plus payant en mettant star genre l'eau
mais le chu skalli par exemple mais mais
sa box christian plourde a accepté de
nous parler pour rendre hommage au
travail de ses anciens collègues le
souvenir d'une équipe dédiée d'une
équipe d'enquêteurs chevronnés qui ont
travaillé extrêmement fort dans des
conditions particulièrement difficiles
et complexes et aussi parce que comme
citoyen ce qu'il dit avoir appris la
choqué mais pas sans savoir qu'il ya des
problèmes les hôpitaux on n'est pas sans
savoir que les problèmes des écoles
louis comme citoyen c'est ce que ça m'a
fait de voir que l'argent qu'ils étaient
perdus
mais le plus atteint et peut-être
janvier sinon il ne connaît pas les
détails de l'enquêté policière
mais ils redoutent que ses soupçons se
confirment boxeur expo vrai tous
terrible après avoir tant travaillé pour
mettre de l'or ça finit comme ça c'est
un coin